هذا المؤتمر الصحفي للقيا في حركه حماس
حنها على شعبنا والتي طالت كل مقومات
الحياه الانسانيه في مجازر يندى لها جبين
البشريه ولم يشهد لها التاريخ الحديث
مثيلا وكل ذلك يحدث امام مراه وسمع العالم
الذي يقف عاجزا او متفرجا لا يحرك ساكنا
لتجريم هذا العدو ولا ادانه افعاله ولا
وقفها وفي شراكه كامله من الاداره
الامريكيه والحكومه البريطانيه مع
الاحتلال النازي في هذه
الجريمه ندعو
بالرحمه والخلود والمجد لشهداء
شعبنا في كل ساحات فلسطين وفي خارج
فلسطين والرحمه كذلك والخلود لشهداء امتنا
الذين الذين ارتقوا في معركه طوفان الاقصى
الخالده في لبنان وفي العراق وفي اليمن
وفي سوريا كما نساله عز وجل ان يمن
بالشفاء العاجل على المرضى والجرحى وان
يكتب الحريه قريبا للاسرى والمعتقلين من
سجون الاحتلال وان يمن بنصر مبين قادم
لشعبنا ومقاومتنا وامتنا واحرار العالم
نراه قريبا باذن الله سبحانه
وتعالى وما جعله الله الا بشرى ولتطمئن به
قلوبكم وما النصر الا من عند الله العزي
ان الله عزيز
حكيم ساتحدث في ثلاثه
عناوين حول العنوان الاول حول تصعيد
المجازر وحرب الاباده الجماعيه اما
العنوان الثاني فهو في المسار الميداني
والسياسي واما العنوان الثالث فهو في
المقاومه في المواقف
الدوليه اولا في تصعيد المجازر وحرب
الاباده الجماعيه التي تشن على شعبنا
لازال الاحتلال يصعد في حربه الهمجيه ضد
مستشفيات قطاع غزه كما بداها في مشفى
الشفائي والرنتيسي والقدس واخرجها هذه
المستشفيات جميعا عن الخدمه قد حصارا
وقصفاً مستشفيات خان يونس ويرتكب فيها
جرائم مروعه بحق النازحين والجرحى والمرضى
بهدف تهجيرهم في جريمه حرب اباده جماعيه
متواصله وان قيام الاحتلال النازي بتدمير
اكثر من 17 مقبره في قطاع غزه 17 مقبره
وانتشال وسرقه جثامين الشهداء والعبث بها
وتشويهها واعادتها بعد سرقه ا قضائها يعد
جريمه صهيونيه متكامله الاركان تعبر عن
ساديه هذا الاحتلال وفاش تلك الساديه التي
فاقت كل الحدود وتجاوزت كل القيم والاعراف
والاخلاق والتشريعات السماويه بل ان هذه
الساديه تعكس وحشيه هي الاسوا في صور
انحطاط البشريه
جمعاء ان مخططات الاحتلال الصهيوني في
ايجاد حزام امني على حدود القطاع عبر
تدمير مربعات سكنيه كامله وتجريف مزارع
ومنشات مدنيه هي جريمه صهيونيه مكشوفه
واعتداء صارخ على ارضنا ومقدراتنا
الفلسطينيه ولن تنجح هذه العمليات في
تحقيق اهداف العدو فشعبنا ومقاومتنا
سيفشلون هذه المخططات بصمودهم
وجهادهم وان تكرار واشنطن دعوتها للاحتلال
الصهيوني حمايه المدنيين وموظفي الاغاثه
والمنشات التابعه للمنظمات الانسانيه في
قطاع غزه منذ بدء العدوان وحتى اليوم ما
هو الا دعايه اعلاميه جوفاء بل هي دعايه
رخيصه لا اثر لها وسط استمرار الدعم
والتاييد والشراكه
الحقيقيه والكامله ل من هذه الاداره
للكيان الصهيوني في حرب الاباده الجماعيه
التي يرتكبها ضد شعبنا من خلال تغذيه اله
القتل العسكريه الصهيونيه عبر الذخائر
والعتاد الذي يتم نقله بجسر جوي وبحري حتى
الان
230 رحله جويه على الاقل مسجله لنقل
العتاد و20 سفينه شحن لنقل العتاد الى
الكيان الصهيوني من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وما العدوان الاخير يوم امس على
مركز تدريب الاونر في خان يونس واحراقه
والصمت الامريكي المريب تجاه ذلك الا
تاكيد لما نقول واضيف ايضا ان المجزره
التي ارتكبت اليوم على دوار الكويت عندما
دعت الانرو النازحين للقدوم للحصول على
المساعدات والاغاثه ثم تم قصفه بالطيران
الصهيوني ما اسفر عن اكثر من 30 شهيد و150
جريح هذه ايضا جريمه تضاف الى هذا السجل
المريب للولايات المتحده من الشراكه
الكامله مع الاحتلال ان استمرار الصمت
والتقاعس الدوليه في وقف هذه الجرائم
والمجازر وحرب الاباده الجماعيه هو سلوك
يصل الى حد التواطئ والشراكه فيه ولا يفهم
الا في سياق الاستسلام للارهاب الصهيوني
المدعوم
امريكيا ثانيا في المسار الميداني
والسياسي في صمود شعبنا وبساله المقاومه
انما يصنعه رجال كتائب المقاومه كتائب
الشهيد عز الدين القسام وسرايا القدس
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه من
ابداعات بطوليه تخلد في تاريخ شعبنا
النضال بل في تاريخ البشريه جمعاء وليس
اخرها عمليه المغازي المضف فره التي باغت
فيها جند القسام جيش العدو النازي واثنوا
في جنوده وضباطه قتلى وجرحى تفوق اعدادهم
ما اعلنه هذا الجيش المهزوم حتى هذه
اللحظه اننا اذ نفتخر بمقاومته الباسله لا
سما بكتائب القسام المضفره وسرايا القدس
المجاهده وبكل قوه المقاومه الموحده في
هذه المعركه المصيريه فاننا نحمد الله
ونثني عليه فبفضله وبتوفيقه للمجاهدين
يصنع مجاهدون الابطال المعجزات واحده تلو
الاخرى وقد راى العالم في المغازي ما قد
تصنعه قذيفه واحده اذ توقع في جيش
الاحتلال كل هذا العدد من القتلى وما رميت
اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى وليبلي المؤمنين
منه بلاء حسنا فالحمد لله اولا واخيرا
ونساله سبحانه المزيد من التوفيق والتسديد
لابطالنا في
الميدان الى جانب ذلك يواصل اهلنا في قطاع
غزه العزه رجالا شبابا نساء
واطفال وعائلات يواصلون صناعه ملحمه
الصمود والثبات
الاسطوريه جسدا واحدا يعجز البيان عن وصف
هذه الملحمه ولا تفي عبارات الثناء
بالوفاء لهم رغم حول القتل والمجازر
المروعه وحرب التجويع والتعطيش والقصف
الممنهج واستهداف كل مقومات الحياه لا
يزال شعبنا صامدا متماسكا متحديا هذا
العدو وان مشهد اركان الحرب الصهاينه مع
نهايات الشهر الرابع لعدوانه النازيه ضد
قطاع غزه يكشف عن تصدع وتاكل داخلي
وارتباك بين قادته المجرمين سياسيين
وعسكريين فهم جميعا على اختلافاتهم
السياسيه والعسكريه عاجزون عن تحقيق اي
هدف من اهداف حربهم العدوانيه وهنا نؤكد
وبوضوح
ان المقاومه وهي تدير هذه المعركه بكل قوه
وحكمه واقتدار وتبلي فيها بلاء حسنا
وتتحكم في ادارتها ف لدماء الشهداء ودفاعا
وحمايه لاهلنا وردا للعدوان تثبت مجددا
انها تمضي بخطا ثابته نحو تحقيق نصر مبين
ضد هذا العدو النازي باذن الله وقوته وان
صمود شعبنا العظيم في قطاع غزه وثباته على
ارضه وتقديمه التضحيات الجسام وهو صابر
مرابط محتسب على مدار اشهر متتاليه
والتفافه حول مقاومته واحتضانه لها بكل
ايمان وقوه هو الصخره التي ستتحطم فوقها
كل مخططات الاحتلال العدوانيه من تهجير او
نيل من حقوق شعبنا وكرامته وهويته وان
المجرم الفاشل نتنياهو يتوهم انه باصراره
على مواصله عدوانه وحرب الاباده الجماعيه
على شعبنا يتوهم انه سيحقق شيئا من اهدافه
ومخططات حربه على ارض غزه خاب وخسر ولن
تكون غزه الا مقبره لاحلام واوهامه
ومخططاته وجيشه باذن الله ويواصل نتنياهو
الفاشل كذبه على جمهوره ويبيع لهم الوهم
ولا يهتم في هذا السياق لاعداد جنوده
القتلى كل يوم ولا يكترث لارواح جن وضباط
جيش الاحتلال الاسرى عند المقاومه بل ان
سياسه المماطله والغط وال الغطرسه التي
يمارسها ستفضي الى مزيد من الخسائر التي
ستعصف بمستقبله السياسي قريبا باذن الله
اننا واذ نتعامل بكل جديه مع مقترحات
وافكار الوسطاء حول وقف العدوان وقفا
شاملا
وكاملا تبادل الاسرى تبادلا شاملا نجدد
التاكيد ان الفرصه الوحيده لعوده الجنود
الصهاينه الاسرى لدى المقاومه عودتهم
احياء الى عائلاتهم لن تكون الا بعد توقف
شامل للعدوان على شعبنا وان كل تسويف او
تاخير في وقف هذا العدوان يعني مزيدا من
القتلى في صفوف هؤلاء الاسرى بسبب استمرار
العدوان على شعبنا ان من يتحمل مسؤوليه
ذلك هو المجرم نتنياهو واركان حربه
ويشاركهم في ذلك الاداره الامريكيه الشريك
الكامل في
الجريمه وهم يتحملون كذلك المسؤوليه
المباشره والكامله عن استمرار حرب الاباده
الجماعيه
وتداعياتها
ونتائجها والتي لن يجننو منها سوى الخيبه
والخسران ثم المحاكمه على جرائم جرائمهم
وعدوانهم بعد ان تعصف بمستقبلهم السياسي
والعسكري ثالثا في المواقف
الدوليه سنبدا من موضوع المحكمه الدوليه
محكمه العدل الدوليه تتابع حركه حماس
باهتمام بالغ مداولات محكمه العدل الدوليه
بعد الطلب الذي قدمته مشكوره دوله جنوب
افريق
الى هذه المحكمه لوقف الاباده الجماعيه ضد
شعبنا وخاصه في غزه وفي ضوء متابعتها تعلن
حماس موقفها والذي يقوم على المبادئ
الاساسيه للمعامله بالمثل والقانون الدولي
متمثلا بما يلي ثلاث
قضايا اولا في حال صدور القرار عن المحكمه
في لهاي بوقف اطلاق النار فان حركه حماس
سوف تلتزم بوقف اطلاق النار ما التزم
العدو
بذلك ثانيا ستقوم الحركه باطلاق سراح
الاسرى الصهاينه المحتجزين لديها اذا
اطلقت دوله الاحتلال سراح الاسرى
الفلسطينين المعتقلين لديها جميعا ثالثا
يجب على العدو ان ينهي حصاره واعني بذلك
الكيان الصهيوني ان ينهي حصاره المستمر
منذ 18 عاما على غزه وان يسمح بشكل كامل
بلا قيود ولا شروط بادخال كافه المساعدات
اللازمه لاغاثه اهلنا في غزه وايضا حاجات
اللازمه لاعاده الاعمار بعد ما خلفه العدو
من دمار في غزه في السياق ذاته
ندعو كل الدول والحكومات والهيئات
الحقوقيه والانسانيه في العالم الى مواصله
رفع دعاوى قضائيه في محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه ضد الاحتلال الصهيوني وضد قادته
السياسيين والعسكريين والامني لتجريم
افعالهم العدوانيه وتقديمهم للمحاكمه
كمجرم حرب كما ندعو الى تكثيف رفع شكاوى
جنائيه ضد المسؤولين الصهاينه في كل الدول
والعواصم التي يزورون من اجل ملاحقه قاده
هذا الكيان الفاشي وفضحه وتجريم افعاله
العدوانيه امام العالم مثال ذلك ما جرى
مؤخرا في سويسرا بالقضيه التي رفعت على
المجرم رئيس الكيان الصهيوني هرتزوغ الذي
كان يوقع على قذائف الطائرات والمدفعيه
التي تطلق على شعبنا وتقتل نسائنا
واطفالنا ان التهجم المتواصل للمجرم
نتنياهو واركان حكومته النازيه من
المتطرفين الصهاينه على دولنا العربيه
والاسلاميه واخرها على دوله قطر الشقيقه
يعبر عن افلاس وفشل سياسي في مواجهه سيل
الانتقادات التي تطالهم دوليا وتحملهم
مسؤوليه وتداعيات حرب الاباده
الجماعيه التي تقع في غزه وتجرم سلوكهم
النازي وهذا يؤكد سلوكهم هذا يؤكد عدم
اكتراث نتنياهو وحكومته بالدور الحيوي
والهام الذي قامت به قطر ولا تزال تقوم به
كوسيط نزيه وفاعل في مفاوضات وقف العدوان
وتبادل الاسرى بل ان هذا الموقف يعبر عن
محاوله للتهرب من جهود انهاء العدوان بشكل
كامل ويعكس ازمه جيشه العميقه في الميدان
نثمن كذلك موقف جمهوريه مصر العربيه
الشقيقه الرافض لاي مخططات للكيان
الصهيوني في احتلال محور فيلادلفيا وفي
تهجير شعبنا من قطاع غزه وندعو دولنا
العربيه والاسلاميه الى دعم هذه المواقف
والعمل بكل الوسائل لوقف العدوان واغاثه
شعبنا ودعم صموده وثباته على ارضه وادخال
كل المساعدات التي يحتاجها شعبنا عبر معبر
رفح رغم رفض الاحتلال
لذلك اود هنا ان اشير الى ما يعرضه بعض
القاده الصهاينه المجرمين على دول اوروبيه
من حلول واقتراحات حول مستقبل قطاع غزه
سواء مقترحات وزير خارجيه العدو العبقري
الذي اقترحنا ان يمنح جائزه اذكى الاغبياء
حول انشاء جزيره صناعيه عائمه في البحر
يتم تهجير شعبنا
اليها ان هذه
الاقتراحات او ما يشابهها من دعوه
لاستقبال ابناء شعبنا في دول اخرى تعبر عن
عقليه الكيان الصهيوني الفاشيه والنازيه
واحلامه المريضه في تهجير شعبنا عن ارضه
ان هذه الاحلام والاوهام لن تتحقق ولن
يكتب لها ان تصبح واقعا فشعبنا راسخ في
ارضه رسوخ الجبال والاحتلال باذن الله الى
زوال وسيعود هؤلاء الغزاه من حيث جاؤوا من
اطراف الارض الاربعه ونؤكد هنا ايضا رفضنا
لتصريحات ما يسمى منسق الاتصالات الاست
استراتيجيه لمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
جون كيربي وغيرها من تصريحات الاداره
الامريكيه حول مستقبل غزه بعد العدوان وان
هذا المستقبل لا يمكن ان يشمل حركه حماس
اننا نعد هذا التصريح تدخلا سافرا في شؤون
شعبنا واستمرارا لنهج الوصايه التي تسعى
من خلالها الاداره الامريكيه الى ابقاء هي
منتها على قرارات واختيارات الشعوب ونرى
هذا السلوك شكلا من اشكال العدوان المرفوض
على شعبنا وقضيتنا ونؤكد اننا مكون اصيل
من مكونات شعبنا وان شعبنا هو صاحب الكلمه
الوحيده في اختيار قيادته وتقرير
مصيره نجدد تثمين للمواقف المشرفه
والجريئه للاخوه في انصار الله في
اليمن الذين يصرون على مواصله استهدافهم
لسفن الكيان الصهيوني انتصارا لفلسطين
والقدس وغزه وتضامنا مع المقاومه في قطاع
غزه حتى يتوقف العدوان الصهيوني وفي هذا
السياق ننظر ببالغ الاستهجان والادانه
ونحذر من المساعي الراميه الى انقاذ
الكيان الصهيوني من وحل مستنقع الهزيمه
الاستراتيجيه التي يمنى بها في قطاع غزه
وهو ما عبرت عنه الوزيره الفاشيه في حكومه
نتنياهو ماري
ريجف عندما تحدثت عن بناء طريق بري يجري
تنسيقه لنقل البضائع القادمه من الهند الى
ميناء عربي عبر اراض عربيه ومن ثم الى
الكيان الصهيوني لتجنب الحظر الذي فرضته
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه الشقيقه على سفن
الاحتلال الصهيوني وهنا نقول وبوضوح ان
الدول العربيه المعنيه بهذا التصريح الذي
صدر عن هذه المجرمه
المتطرفه
مطالبه بتوضيح موقفها مما تفوهت به
واقترحت فنحن اليوم امام استحقاق تاريخي
لا يقبل انصاف المواقف ولا انصاف الحلول
وندعو جماهير امتنا العربيه والاسلاميه
والاحرار في العالم كله الى مواصله وتصعيد
كل الجهود واشكال التضامن والحراك في كل
الساحات وبكل الوسائل في مدن وعواصم
العالم فضحا للاحتلال ورفضا لجرائمه
وتضامنا مع شعبنا وقضيتنا العادله حتى
يتوقف العدوان الصهيوني ونجدد دعوتنا لهم
جميعا للخروج غدا الجمعه ويومي السبت
والاحد القادمين ورفع الصوت عاليا في كل
ساحات العالم من اجل الضغط على قاده
وزعماء الدول والحكومات لفتح المعابر
وادخال المساعدات ومنع موت شعبنا في قطاع
غزه جوعا وعطشا ومرضا ووقف حرب الاباده
الجماعيه المتطرفون من
المستوطنين منذ يومين يقطعون الطريق لدخول
الطحين الى قطاع غزه باعتبار انهم يريدون
دعم المعركه التي يشنها الجيش على شعبنا
هذه رساله ينبغي ان يتلقاها ويفهمها كل
مطمن مع قضيتنا اختم بالدعاء بالرحمه
لقوافل شهداء شعبنا وامتنا الابرار
والدعاء بالشفاء لجرحانا ومرضانا والحريه
لاسرانا ومعتقلي في سجون العدو الصهيوني
والنصر لشعبنا ومقاومتنا وما النصر الا من
عند الله وانه لجهاد نصر او استشهاد
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
اسئله العدو الاسرائيلي يقول ان حماس
تطالب وقف اطلاق النار وضمانات لبقاء اهل
السلطه وعدم استهدافها مستقبل ما تعليق
على
هذا يعني ما يطرحه العدو ثلاث مسائل ان
حماس تطالب بوقف العدوان ويدعي انها تطالب
بضمانات للبقاء بالسلطه وضمانات بعدم
الاستهداف اولا مطلبنا بوقف كامل وشامل
للعدوان هو مطلب واضح يعني نحن طالب بذلك
من اليوم الاول وندعو له
و ما زلنا في الميدان نقاوم الاحتلال
ليصبح هذا الوقف امرا
واقعا اما الحديث عن انه حماس تريد ضمانات
لحمايه نفسها الذي يريد ان يحمي نفسه اي
يمكن ان يقدم فروض الطاعه والولاء للكيان
الصهيوني ويقبل بوجود هذا الكيان الصهيوني
ويستسلم لارادته وعندها يمكن ان يقتل بدم
بارد نحن لم نفكر يوما الا في حمايه
قضيتنا وفي تحرير ارضنا وفي حمايه شعبنا
والكل يعرف انه في هذه المعركه تقدم قوافل
الشهداء قاد في حركه حماس سواء من جناحها
العسكري او قيادتها السياسيه
وهم في الميدان بين ابناء شعبهم ولذلك هذا
الطرح الذي يقدمه الاسرائيلي هو جزء من
حمله اشاعات تهدف الى التشويش على ليس على
موقف الحركه وانما على الجهود التي تبذل
من اجل وقف اطلاق النار بشكل كامل ومن اجل
اجراء تبادل الاسرى نتنياهو لا يريد ذلك
وفي نفس الوقت يعاني من
ضغوط الشارع الاسرائيلي فيسوق مثل هذه هذه
الاشاعات نعم نحن نريد وقفا شاملا كاملا
لاطلاق النار يكون قاعده لاي تفاهم حول
اطلاق الاسرى لكن حمايه انفسنا نحن سنتو
من خلال التحام بشعبنا فشعبنا هو الذي
يوفر الحمايه لقضيتنا وقضيته وهو الذي
يصنع النصر ونحن جزء من شعبنا في
هذا جلن فقول الاشخاص الاكثر تطرفا في
المفاوضات مع حماس هم الاشخاص الاكثر بعدا
عن غزه وبقصد فيها قياده حركه حماس في
الخارج بيحكي عن قياده حركه حماس وعن بيزع
عن بعض الامور والسفريات قياده الحركه
الخارج هل هناك خلاف داخل قياده حركه حماس
حول موضوع
المفوضات شوف هذه اسطوانه مشروخه و
سمفونيه قديمه وانا اعتقد ان تصريح جلنت
ينطلق من اربع عناوين العنوان الاول هناك
ازمه حق حقيقيه داخل حكومه الاحتلال
وهناك صراع وصل كما تتحدث مصادر الاحتلال
الى حد الاشتباك بالايدي بين بعض القيادات
والمسؤولين وجلن نفسه منع سكرتيره العسكري
من دخول الاجتماع لانه اهم بالتسجيل
والتسريب للاعلام وهو يقاطع مؤتمرات صحفيه
يعقدها رئيسه وهكذا اذا هو يحاول ان يقول
انه ليست الازمه في في جبهه واحده وانما
الازمه على الجبهه الاخرى السبب الثاني او
الخلفيه الثانيه هو كان يتحدث في الميدان
يعني هو ذهب لزياره الجنود بعد عمليه
المغازي البطوليه يحاول ان يرفع معنوياتهم
فيقول لهم ان هناك خلافات داخل هذه
المقاومه وان عليهم ان يتماسكوا في
الميدان قليلا لعل ذلك يؤدي الى تحقيق
انجاز وانتصار وهو واهم بل هو يعرف تماما
ان هذا غير ممكن وانما يحاول ان يرفع من
الروح المعنويه
لجنوده اما الجانب الثالث
فهو يعبر عن غيظه ان هناك تماسك في قياده
حركه حماس وان هذه القياده هي عباره عن
مؤسسه وهو يدرك تماما ان كل ما ورد الينا
من اقتراحات ومن افكار تم التداول فيه في
قياده الحركه وعندما اتحدث عن قياده
الحركه فانني اتحدث عن ابناء عن اعضاء هذه
القياده في داخل فلسطين وفي خارجها وفي
قطاع كذلك وكل ما ياتي من افكار واراء هو
خلاصه هذا الحوار داخل القياده التي تعمل
بشكل مؤسسي كما تعود عليها العالم دائما
وبالتالي هو يغتاظ لان هناك موقف واضح
تقدمه الحركه بناء على دور او عمل مؤسسي
فيما الاشتباك واضح داخل مؤسسه القياده
الصهيونيه واعني بذلك حكومه نتنياهو اما
المساله الرابعه والوجه الرابع لهذا
التصريح
جلنت
وحكومته يغيظهم حجم التعاطف المتصاعد في
العالم مع القضيه الفلسطينيه واصرار
العالم اليوم على اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
كحل للصراع ويغتاظ لان حركه حماس تتصاعد
شعبيتها على مستوى الشعب الفلسطيني والامه
وتفتح لها الابواب وتستقبل في دول كثيره
هذا لا شك يغي هوو يحاول ان يتهم حركه
حماس بالارهاب ويجد ان حماس تفتح لها
الابواب وهو الذي تلتصق او تنكشف حقيقته
السوداء من انه ارهابي وان حكومته ارهابيه
وان جيشه وجيش ارهابي لا يعرف قيما ولا
اخلاقا ولا امرا حميدا شكرا لكم